أريد أن أذهب مباشرة إلى شيكاغو والدكتور
زهار سهول، المؤسس المشارك ورئيس
Med Global، وهي منظمة موجودة على
الأرض في غزة للمساعدة في تلبية
الاحتياجات الطبية الماسة هناك، شكرًا جزيلاً
لوجودك هنا معنا، لذلك هذا
التوغل الكبير من قبل  إسرائيل، ما هو التأثير الذي تعتقد أن
هذا قد يحدثه على الفئات الأكثر
ضعفًا في غزة، مليون طفل أو نحو ذلك
هناك والذين
يعانون بالفعل، أشكركم على استضافتي
للوضع حتى قبل هذا
الغزو البري، كان هناك حركة مرور كارثية
وأه مع الحصار و
منع الغذاء والدواء والإمدادات
الطبية والمياه النظيفة
الوضع لا أستطيع أن أتخيل ما
يحدث الآن للمدنيين
في غزة والآن مع
الغزو البري الذي سيعقد أكثر
وسيسبب المزيد من الهجمات على
المدنيين المزيد من القنابل أه أكثر  إصابات أه
للأسف 23 من الإصابات
نساء وأطفال عدد كبير جدا
من الأطفال الذين قتلوا وأصيبوا
أه وأيضا من المحتمل أن ينهار
ما تبقى من الجهاز الطبي الذي
أه آخر 2 ثلث طاقته أه
بسبب استهلاك المواد الاستهلاكية بشكل
كبير  عدد المستلزمات الطبية كل
يوم خلال هذه الأزمة ما يستهلك
في المستشفى يساوي
استهلاك شهر قبل الأزمة ومن ثم
يمكنك إضافة إليها قلة
المياه النظيفة التي تسبب الكثير من أه
العدوى المنقولة بالمياه أه نقصك
الكهرباء يعني أن العديد من الوظائف الأساسية
للمستشفيات ستتوقف عن العمل
بما في ذلك أجهزة التنفس الصناعي والحاضنات أه المعامل
أو وحدات غسيل الكلى 1000 مريض في
غسيل الكلى من المحتمل أن يموتوا أه إذا
لم يكن هناك أه عاجل أه إمدادات من أدوات غسيل الكلى
إلى جانب 135 مولودًا جديدًا وهم
حاضنات سيكون الوضع
لا يمكن تصوره وأبعد من
الكارثة، نعم حيث يحاول الأطباء مساعدة
هؤلاء الأطفال الذين تضرروا من
النظام الطبي كما تقول على وشك
الانهيار، أعني أنك ذهبت إلى العديد من
مناطق الكوارث المختلفة بنفسك
مما تراه، أعني هو  هذا هو
أسوأ ما
رأيته لقد كنت في أوكرانيا لقد كنت في
سوريا لقد كنت في اليمن أم في الواقع لقد
جئت للتو من أوكرانيا منذ شهر
وهذا هو أسوأ ما رأيته على الإطلاق
في غزة أربع مرات من قبل
وشهدت غزة حروب قبل هذه هي
الحرب الكبيرة الخامسة في آخر 20 سنة ولكن
هذه أسوأ ما رأيته في
العالم كله وأعتقد أن عواقب
هذه الحرب أه ستستمر في التأثير
على  الناس في غزة وخارجها
للأجيال القادمة، لا يقتصر الأمر على
الجروح الجسدية والوفيات
والإصابات بين العائلات، بل أيضًا على
جروح الصحة العقلية التي ستدوم إلى
الأبد بين الأطفال الذين
يشهدون القصف والذين فقدوا العديد من
أفراد أسرهم.  هام أبو صفية
وهو طبيب الأطفال الرئيسي لدينا
كانت رسالته الأخيرة قبل 36 ساعة أخبرني إذا
بقيت على قيد الحياة أود أن أتحدث أكثر
عن مريضتي الأخيرة لقد رأى مريضًا
اسمها ديما وهي طفلة تبلغ من
العمر 10 سنوات فقط وقد فقدت  جميع
أفراد عائلتها (والديها وستة
إخوة وأخوات) وقد أصيبت
بكسر في جمجمتها وكسر في
أطرافها وإصابات في الكبد والطحال
وليس لديهم ما يكفي من
الإمدادات لعلاجها وكان كذلك
آسف جدًا وأخبرني أن أتعس شيء
لديه في حياته هو أنه
شهد العديد من الأطفال الذين رآهم في
الأحياء وهم الآن موتى
ومشوهين وهذا شيء
لا ينبغي أن يحدث في القرن الحادي والعشرين